eu ministers meeting in the context of
the education youth culture and sport
council adopted conclusions on the
european audio-visual policy in the
digital era
the overall aim of the of the cancer
conclusions is of course to pave the way
uh to a
urgently required the review of the
audio visual media service directive
which is almost 10 years old even more
and hopefully actually by next year
according to the council the future
approach to european audiovisual policy
should ensure cultural and linguistic
diversity in the media and increase the
competitiveness of the european audio
visual sector
ministers also established a work plan
for culture setting out the priorities
for cooperation in cultural policy
making over the next four years
one of the topics discussed here was the
treatment of printed and electronic
books from a taxation point of view
ministers agreed also in a new framework
to promote a more active involvement of
civil society and private organizations
in the promotion of europe's cultural
heritage
in the afternoon ministers looked at the
potential of sport as a driver for
innovation and growth in europe and
insisted on the need to develop
proactive policies to promote sport and
physical activity especially amongst
children
you